aracles in I'm here for man in the high
castle Eric 20 years did it take to get
this television show made and how did it
find the house well I was hired to join
the show for season two also I know from
the novel which was written decades ago
the producers of the original producers
of the series struggled for many many
years bring it to the train it was a
long development process over a decade
so I was fortunate enough to be brought
on and keeping to as you already watch
the show oh yes I walk hip I'd watched
all of season one and I came on board
and ended up being the head writer of do
you remember when you sat down to write
let's say I don't know if you did a spec
script for them or how the process was
but what was the first presentation of
your work he presented to well I had
written on 15 other television series
prior to man in the high castle so my
work was kind of known i'm also an
executive producer so they knew I spend
a lot of a lot of the other aspects to
go along with writing a big fella
Angelica but the thing that I'd written
that probably put me most in contention
I'd written a pilot about Nazi occupied
Paris which was a historically based
pilot and so I think a lot of the folks
read back said oh he knows how to do not
see show okay what are your first steps
for writing a screenplay you have a sort
of a tried-and-true the set of rules
that you use or no is everything is
different every time well my process
evolves every time I do another job I
realized how much I didn't know and my
prior job so if I'm somebody who reads
pretty much every trick every screen
writing book every strip that i can get
my hand
and I'm constantly trying to evolve as a
craftsman I also unfortunate enough in
this job to surround myself with really
talented people and you learn a lot from
other writers like there were writers on
on l'anima highcastle won Emmys or you
know martin scorsese's best friend is
another one like like you want to really
kind of learn from from the people
around you and that just makes you
better so I can't say that I have any
set process although right now as I'm
developing something I have to say I'm a
big fan of the John true be John true
barista I think he kind of hits the
sweet spot for me but you know I've
taken them all shaken Vicki I've taken
everyone not I'm one of these guys you
it likes to learn these stuff about the
craft and I figure if I can learn
something from any book if I get one
thing out of it makes me a better writer
that's kind of but I'm all for it have
you ever written a screenplay that has
no structure I am more of a planner than
a pan-cancer like obviously like stephen
king will say squares by the heat of
your hands approach but I'm much more of
a
an outliner and engineer when it comes
to that and then you throw that out and
then you and then you let the character
treat you and you get in the moment and
things change but but I also i'm a big
fan of pressure i am i know i haven't
just sat down and tried to write
something of a final product from page
one i I kind of construct it over time
I'm a grinder I guess you can say when
you begin to write are you envisioning
the people watching the final product or
that doesn't even enter into your mind
you're you're you're so involved in the
beginning and what's in your head well I
do you want to keep the audience in mind
someone but but you also don't want to
pander like if you're in the moment much
as an actor is in the moment you're
trying to find the humanity and the
truth behind what you're writing about
in any kind of weather you're doing a
superhero show when you're doing a you
know a big deep socio-political show
like them in the High Council you want
to actually find yourself lost in the
moment and how the characters are
speaking to each other as real people
and and that's some of discovery that
happens when you have enough for me we
have enough of the structure figured out
that you have the correct characters and
social then you're in the moment and
they start to talk to you when it works
speaking of talking this will be my last
question but with dialogue how much are
you refining the dialogue and and making
sure that you're researching it for that
specific time period and trying it out
on other people constantly I mean this
is a constant polished process that goes
on for dialogue and also we had
researchers who were looking to make
sure that we didn't
use words which didn't exist in today
and sometimes they would catch us
excessive thinkin of you know an
anachronistic modern kind of like oh
yeah that doesn't work we have to change
the life because of course we all are
creatures of pop culture as well so
maybe my High Council which takes place
in the early sixties I had a you know
avoid references to some of my favorite
superhero ok any other terminology or
definitely not the word bro I mean you
know there's a some part of the culture
now but I mean we're certain things
definitely in the 60s we weren't even
realizing that it wasn't part of the
vernacular right well I mean in the case
of man in the high castle it's an
alternative world also where history
have turned out differently from the
tale of World War two so a lot of the
language that we would use in a first
draft kind of would be slightly
different like given the way the world
turns out and cultural experience and
minimal castle white people are not you
know the over class and the Pacific
States they are kind of treated as as a
as a press minority and so there's all
sorts of textures but that feed into the
language when you have that kind of a
toilet so it's in all history storylines
and language it was very important to us
and we had a lot of very smart people
making sure that we were polishing it up
right to the moment suspect cameras
rolled excellent thank you Eric